[Music]
hey i want to talk to you about
something sexually related uh how can i
help oh my goodness
that's not quite what i had in mind but
why not uh
the olympics
you performed at the olympics closing
ceremony you sang i am the walrus in
front of eight billion people nationwide
and worldwide yeah spinning blue globe
we call earth that's right we live on
earth of course nerve-wracking encounter
because although i was charged and
invited to dress up as willy wonka stand
on top of a psychedelic bus sing i am
the walrus
uh sometimes if i've got a live
microphone i was just saying what i feel
like saying
uh-oh well were they were the olympic
people worried about what you might say
i mean they took a big risk handing you
a microphone you can see a look of dread
on those people's faces as the reality
of what they've got themselves into
came upon them yeah they said you're
just gonna sing on the walrus i said
that'll be one of the things i might do
while i'm out there
this is a chance to express myself
but you you didn't go too crazy now but
what i wanted to ask you about is it was
a very uh well-known talked about story
that in the olympic village a lot of the
athletes were hooking up a lot of uh the
very sexually adventurous people there
uh you're a single man did you uh
yeah
what would you do there what's that
hockey team you're getting at
no did you lift any packages and put
them on shelves get them right up there
well you know you know you're you like
to have a good time did you uh meet any
ladies any olympic ladies while you were
there i saw a couple of athletes
drifting about the place but the thing
is is they're usually quite fast
[Laughter]
with all manner of prophylactics unlike
in the delightful california
process in the porn industry you're not
allowed a condom no more or you have to
have a condom yeah you clearly weren't
watching the show you must
i was watching those colorful ladies yes
uh and i don't blame you but you must
watch uh yes you you you must wear a
condom if you're in a porno yes well
that's gonna take the fun out of it
one of the many highlights of being in
the porn industry is unprotected sex i'm
not in the porn industry i don't know
why i'm saying that in the in the
olympic village
i didn't think you were coming in that
class eventually we would merge what you
and i well if we just kept moving closer
and closer to each other andy could hug
us into one glorious ectoplasm of man
i think that's what they want to see
happen eventually people eventually will
tire of conventional entertainment and
demand ectoplasm
that's my prediction okay but that won't
happen if you have to wear condoms in
porn right
so you're against them and end up in a
bag okay oh uh so you're against condoms
in porn you think it's gonna ruin it
well to tell you the truth let's face it
porn is it's a bit of a dark place isn't
it people are exploited but try not to
think that while you're masturbating it
will ruin it
don't think of the consequences
[Applause]